anna jugó cinco rondas de golf y su
puntaje más bajo fue de 80 los puntajes
de las primeras cuatro rondas y la ronda
más baja se muestran en la siguiente
gráfica de puntos aquí vemos el puntaje
más bajo que es de 80 también vemos que
obtuvo 90 92 94 y 96 se encontró que
anna no cumplió algunas reglas cuando
obtuvo el puntaje de 80 así que parece
que no le sirvió hacer trampa por lo que
ese puntaje se elimina del conjunto de
datos así que se quitó este 80 de acá y
sólo quedaron los puntajes de las otras
cuatro rondas como afectará a la media y
la mediana la eliminación de la ronda de
menor puntaje analicemos primero la
mediana la mediana es el número de en
medio por lo que aquí cuando tenemos
cinco datos el dato de en medio va a ser
el que tenga dos números a la izquierda
y dos números a la derecha en este caso
la mediana es 92 y cuál es la mediana
cuando se quita este 80 ahora tenemos
cuatro datos por lo que queremos
encontrar la mediana dentro de un
conjunto de elementos pares así que nos
fijamos en los dos números de enmedio
que son
92 y el 94 y calculamos el promedio de
estos dos números encontramos el punto
medio entre ambos números así que ahora
la mediana va a hacer 93 que está entre
92 y 94 en este caso eliminar el dato de
menor puntaje incremento la mediana lo
escribimos la mediana incremento que le
va a ocurrir a la media una forma de
pensar en esto sin hacer cálculos es que
si eliminamos un número que es menor que
la media actual y no hemos calculado
cuál es la media actual la media va a
incrementar espero que esto les dé una
idea de lo que está ocurriendo aquí si
eliminamos un número mayor que la media
actual la media va a disminuir porque ya
no tenemos ese número más grande si
eliminamos un número menor que la media
actual al no tener ese número pequeño
que halle el promedio hacia abajo la
media va a incrementar pero vamos a
verificar esto matemáticamente vamos a
calcular la media de esto sumamos 80 más
90 más 92 más 94 96 estos son todos
nuestros datos 2
46 es 12 llevamos 11 8 9 y tenemos este
9 más otros 49 por lo que tenemos 5 9 9
por 5 es 45 así que la suma es 452 esta
es la suma de los puntajes de las cinco
rondas ahora dividimos esto entre el
número de rondas por lo que 452 entre 5
nos da 5 cabe nueve veces en 45 45 45 es
0 y bajamos el 25 caben 20 veces 0 por
50 2 - 0 es 2 nos sobran 2 aquí podemos
decir que la media es 92 puntos la media
va a estar más o menos por acá y si
quitamos el 80 aquí será igual la media
90 más 92 94 96 los sumamos y nos da 24
6 es 12 llevamos 1 sumamos esto y nos da
37 el resultado de la suma es 372 lo
dividimos entre 4 y nos da 4 cabe 9
veces
en 37 9 x 4 es 36 37
36 es 1 bajamos el 2 y el 4 cabe
exactamente tres veces en 12 3 por 4 es
12 12 menos 12 es 0 sin residuo en este
caso tanto la media como la mediana son
iguales a 93 vemos que la mediana pasó
de 92 a 93 por lo que incrementó la
media pasó de 92 quintos a 93 por lo que
la media incrementó más que la mediana
ambas se incrementaron pero la media
incrementó más lo que tiene sentido
porque este número estaba muy por debajo
de todos los otros datos así que al
quitarlo la media incrementa una buena
cantidad
veamos si alguna de las opciones
describe lo que acabamos de encontrar
tanto la media como la mediana
disminuirán pero la media disminuirá más
que la mediana no ésta no es tanto la
media como la mediana disminuirán pero
la mediana disminuirá más que la media
no tampoco tanto la media como la
mediana incrementarán pero la media
incrementará más que la mediana ésta
describe exactamente lo que encontramos
paso de 92 quintos o 90.4 a 93 mientras
que la mediana pasó de 92 93 sólo
incrementó un punto así que esta es la
respuesta correcta nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo